joining us tonight to talk about all of
this plus other big foreign policy
issues
former secretary of state mike pompeo
good to see you mr secretary
fred it's good to be with you
your thoughts on this climate summit you
had a handful of countries that
signed on to the goal of cutting
emissions
by 50 more than 50 percent in the next
decade but some countries did not
there was some criticism of your
administration former president trump's
administration
and how you dealt with climate change
brett the decision for the united states
to re-enter the paris climate accord and
then the announcement that the
president made today is an enormous gift
to the chinese communist party and a
real threat to the united states of
america
it's a domestic threat this will destroy
tens and tens of thousands of jobs all
across the united states it's an
international threat when i was a
secretary of state
our capacity to deliver lng and
petroleum across the world gave us
enormous
global power our ability to reach them
and help them turn the lights on in
their countries and build out their
economies
give us enormous diplomatic reach and
then i guess let's say finally this
bread if you think that the chinese
communist party has any intention of
delivering on any commitment it's made
you just haven't been watching you
haven't been watching hong kong you
haven't been watching xinjiang
you haven't watched it they're done to
christians and tibetans you certainly
haven't watched what they the
commitments that they've made to the
people on taiwan
distrust but verify was our model when
dealing with the chinese
for the bad administration to think they
achieved a victory today because china
made some
in the air misty-eyed good wonderful
feeling summit commitment
is just plain being played for a patsy
here's your successor talking about uh
this day and talking
reflecting back to to how you all
handled it
we want every country here to know we
want to work with you
to save our planet and we're pers we're
all committed to finding every
possible avenue of cooperation on
climate
there are many issues on which we don't
all see
eye to eye this isn't one of them
some of those countries said they held
felt this
breath of relief that they were dealing
with the u.s that was
into deep fighting climate change is
that fair looking backwards
you know brett we were very clear it was
america first they have traded that
very clearly for climate change first
that is not good for american security
it won't lead to better outcomes more
prosperity for us here at home
we care deeply about clean air and clean
drinking water we
every republican does that i've ever met
but to think that you're going to do
this by putting these
these rules a top-down command
focused economy that is going to just
have more cylinders more disasters
because we will waste american taxpayers
money you're going to deliver really
good outcomes i think that's just silly
to
hope that that will happen this will
turn out to be enormously expensive
especially for the hard-working men and
women all across america all across
america
but you agree climate change is an issue
that needs to be dealt with
we've all got to do everything we can to
make sure that we are
science-based we're focused on making
sure that we get it right with respect
to
our environment nobody i'm from kansas
our farmers spend more time thinking
about how to keep their rivers and soil
clean and keep the air clean than
anybody else all across the world they
care about this deeply it's important to
them and for their grandchildren
i don't think anybody disputes the fact
that we need to make sure that we have a
focus on keeping our environment safe
i want to turn to a couple of other
issues iran the administration
is signaling uh pulling back sanctions
perhaps as they're trying to get back
into this iran nuclear deal today
the head of centcom said that the
iranians are making
big strides he said quantitative
remarkable improvements in their
ballistic missile force
at the same time your thoughts on all of
this
well to go back into the jcpoa would be
an enormous mistake
and to lift these sanctions sanctions
that we built up over the course of
four years that had put real constraints
on iran's capacity
would be a big mistake you know these
stories right these are terrorists and
they're not going to go declare that
these are not terrorists
i don't see how one can in good faith do
that
they never got a deal that approached
anything that would attack the ballistic
missile program that that general
referred to
we in the other hand denied them over
121 billion dollars in foreign exchange
reserves they had to make
difficult choices about their programs
and america was more secure because of
it we had
with great partners and friends too it
was in america alone the arab states and
israel working alongside of us had iran
more isolated than in any time in
history
afghanistan uh some concerns from the
centcom commander today
also up on capitol hill about possible
taliban attacks as the u.s gets to
pulling out troops he said it's going to
zero
that's something you support and the
president president trump
pushed for but are there concerns in
your mind about how this all happens
yes brett the execution of this has to
be
flawless it has to be done well and the
administration needs to make very clear
that should the taliban make a choice
that's different than the one they've
made for now what's almost the last year
and a half
we haven't had an american soldier
killed there since the agreement that
our administration entered into the
taliban back in the beginning of 2020.
if the taliban changes direction if they
attack an american we need to respond
with the full fire and fury of the
united states of america
we need to make that clear to them they
need to understand and if we do
we'll deter them and if we don't they'll
attack us and we'll have americans put
at risk i
i hope that's not what happens when you
pick a date certain
this far in advance you certainly
increase the risk of that
finally immigration vice president
harris saying she is going to meet
with the leader in guatemala talking
about the northern triangle
countries saying that the potential is
there but it's not going to be
accomplished overnight
thoughts on how they're dealing with
this and focusing on what they say root
causes in the northern triangle
countries
it's funny brett to say that it's not
going to be solved overnight it was
solved before they came into office
we had made enormous progress i spent a
lot of time with the
leaders in honduras el salvador and
guatemala we had an arrangement with
them as well as with the mexican
government that had delivered american
sovereignty we had
secured our border we were finishing out
the building of the wall and we had
diminished
the magnet that drew these people north
that now you can see when you
when you undid it when you undid what
the trump administration had
delivered well it created the magnet
again and now you have a national
security crisis a health crisis
with people coming across not being
tested for the wuhan virus
and a humanitarian crisis of staggering
proportions no they it could actually be
done
almost overnight if they would simply go
back to the policies that the trump
administration had in place
is the bond administration doing
anything good right now
oh yes no they definitely are i was
pleased to see secretary blinken declare
that
it was in fact genocide taking place in
western china
the language that they have used around
the people of hong kong and some of the
sanctions they put in place there
those are all good things i want to
support what this administration is
doing where we can but but
where they're weak and where they're
risking the deterrence that we build up
it's important that the american people
understand that risk very clearly
because it impacts each and every one of
them
former secretary of state mike pompeo
fox news contributor
thank you thank you brett